foreign
ly Infamous piece that came out in the
Atlantic this week
written by Emily Oster uh asking for uh
amnesty
um not even asking for forgiveness and
not apologizing
but asking for amnesty for those who got
it
so wrong
and during coven and it does seem to me
that that is exactly what many on team
blue in power especially in the public
health apparatus you know that racket
did a tremendous amount of damage to
people killed people damaged people
broke up families destroyed income
streams made the last moments of lives
for people
um bereft of meaning and alone and the
idea that you would ask for amnesty
without yet recognizing the errors and
without yet fixing them and without even
an apology
is remarkable and it will work for some
but it will work mostly for those who
were kind of on the fence and we're kind
of maybe feeling a little bit bad but
didn't really do that much and for the
most part those who have been clear-eyed
and seen it or who've been the at the in
the brunt in the you know in the
the focus of some of the the hatred and
the actual misinformation or the actual
disinformation
um what what that article
saw coming back at it what the author
Oster did presumably and went the
Atlantic the publication didn't the
Atlantic and publication that I once
loved
saw coming back at it was
in no small part anger and it is
Justified anger and so you know what
what this election in part is standing
for legitimately what you are saying is
actually this is really important
because while we don't expect either
party to be interested in actually
governing as insane a sentiment as that
is it is possible that at this moment if
there is a turnover in power that the
team red would actually choose to govern
because they can see because it would be
clear that that was about a deep
frustration and that is underselling at
tremendously a deep frustration on the
part of the populace who have been
gaslit and damaged and lied to and told
to just suck it up and forgive and like
no it's like we're gonna need a lot more
before that is going to happen we're
going to need a lot more I do think
the amnesty discussion as much as uh
uh it was a unbelievably audacious uh
and asinine request really especially
Camp coming from where it did emerge
from yeah we have two tiers right there
are people who made serious errors
interpersonal errors and those people
need to own up and yes we need to accept
them back into our lives and that would
be a bit painful but amnesty has a role
here and frankly if you're higher up
um we
ought to think very carefully I think
we're talking about I'm sorry but when
you're talking about individuals in your
family and many people many people
really do feel I think legitimate like
I'm so hurt and I'm so betrayed and I
missed the important moments and I was
forbidden from attending you know
Christmas and birthdays and all of these
things and
I will forgive and I will move on with
my family but that's not amnesty right
amnesty is a bigger societal level thing
so that's not amnesty that's forgiveness
I agree and forgiveness yes when you
know when when warranted and I want to
point out uh it was a a minister in
Canada we may have even talked about
this I'm not sure there's a piece of
video that circulated a couple weeks ago
in which a minister in Canada was
confronted over the fact of the firing
of a state employee for not complying
with the vaccine mandates and you're not
talking about a religious person you're
talking about the head of state of
Alberta yeah yeah correct yeah I don't
remember her name but the newly elected
head of state of Alberta and I don't
remember if I don't think she's called
the Prime Minister but maybe but the
newly elected head of state of Alberta
when asked on stage and you know what
you know when do you think that we might
begin to see apologies and reversals of
mandates and stuff she says I will
apologize right now she said right now
and then and then she goes on to say and
I will do what's in my power to get you
rehired if you wish to rejoin us and my
feeling is that is exactly the behavior
that we have to have somebody
recognizing their own error owning up to
it doing what they can it wasn't her
error though
the error of her government which she
has just obtained a position of power in
which she can do something about it this
this was not her saying I was wrong
because I don't think she had been wrong
well I if that's true it changes it a
little bit but nonetheless it is the
behavior we should want if she didn't do
anything wrong and she's apologizing for
others it's a little
it's different it's more in the realm of
reparations but I do think that that's
the city yeah more in the realm of
reparations is a good way to put it
right apologizing for a historic wrong
um but but she was elected on this wave
of anger and frustration and with the
hope that she might do something about
it and so she is and so she did and not
just apologize but attempt to repair so
that's that's what we want
um and there's a lot of room you know
there's a lot of room for repair that
comes from an airing of the full
totality of what happened and how it
worked and everything we could learn
because the key thing is to discover
what happened so that this can't happen
again not only on this topic but any
topic because the real story here is the
complete Corruption of the system that
allowed this to go down the way it did
right that corruption is a threat era if
covid vanished tomorrow that corruption
doesn't get any safer
foreign
[Music]